what's up guys it's Jerry here coming at
ya it's night time woo spooky ah but
what better circumstances under which to
recorder of you know it's gonna be the
subject of remakes is very tenuous one
remakes reboot Sri imaginings
revitalization of old properties this is
a topic of much debate and even much
outcry these days in terms of the modern
cinematic landscape and uh it seems
clear that like it or not remakes for
the time being are very much here to
stay there basically a genre ended up
themselves and as such remakes are very
problematic especially horror remakes
because we get so many of those and that
becomes problematic because first and
foremost you have these these two tiers
it seems like at least for horror remix
you have the big-budget sort of
Hollywood studio remake you know you're
20 to 60 million dollar range remake and
then you have your low or micro budget
independent remake and sad as it is to
say there is a market difference that
seems to be pretty consistent between
the two I'm not at all the type who
likes to judge movies based on budgets
however more often than not it seems
like if you look at a low-budget
independent remake your chances of it
being anything that's interesting or
fresh increase exponentially when
compared to you know the big studio big
money remix and you couldn't tell
already I'm talking about poltergeists
it's the movie I saw this past weekend
and this is a studio remake of a classic
and I wish I could say this breaks the
cycle but unfortunately for me anyway it
doesn't it it sadly perpetuates the
cycle I feel like and remakes are
further troublesome because you know it
doesn't seem like there's any agreeable
criterion or set of criteria on which to
assess a horror remake her to take one
in and for me you know what I usually
look for
is just something that at least tries
you know try to bring some fresh ideas
try to justify your existence because
you never know who's gonna have a fresh
idea who's gonna have a new take on an
idea and that can be fun to see a
different artist take on a story we've
seen before it's just that with so much
money on the line Studios aren't
inclined to take that kind of a chance
or to engage that way and poltergeist is
kind of an example of this this movie
begins in the same territory the
original poltergeist does you know you
have this family they're down on their
luck the father has just been laid off
and they have to move into a new
neighborhood and the kids aren't psyched
about it at all and as they're getting
settled in they start to experience
these strange phenomena they start to
experience a visitation by a mischievous
and ultimately malevolent spirit a
poltergeist and this movie part of the
trouble is this one does what so many of
them do which is it spends a lot of time
foreshadowing and building up moments
and going remember poltergeist and that
really starts to kill the suspense after
a while you know it's like when they
arrived at the house immediately there's
a massive shot where they zoom into the
tree and they're like look it's the tree
look it's the dreary Sri look it's the
look the latrine
yeah I'm like I know like I know it's
coming don't don't tell me I feel like
this movie could have really benefited
from you know approaching it as if we
all hadn't seen it and weren't
intimately familiar with the details of
the story because this movie really
leaves nothing to the imagination that
way everything is telegraphed and
everything goes look remember
poltergeist and I'm like yes I do
perhaps why don't you surprise me with
some and you have this family that's
supposedly down on their luck but you
know we we joined them moving into a
pretty big house in a pretty nice
neighborhood despite the fact that they
keep telling us it's shitty this movie
seems to brush over their situation in
an effort to seem conversational but
like you know you can't show me one
scene where Sam Rockwell's credit cards
get declined and then expect that to
cover the believability of that part of
the story but what before for a whole
90-minute experience tree you're the
cast here for the most part it's all
pretty good I mean rosemarie dewitt is
really good Jane Addams is really good
Jared Harris is good Sam Rockwell's good
I'm i liked his performance although i
feel like it's just suited to a
different movie he's got this kind of
dry width that doesn't exactly fit here
and then you have jared harris who like
is introduced on this paranormal
investigation show or web series and its
kind of tongue-in-cheek and then when
you meet him on camera when he actually
enters the movie it's like Naruto but
he's a badass though like he's the real
deal and the way they orchestrated that
doesn't ever click or at least it didn't
for me I was like who do you want this
character to be and then you have the
kids and like the young daughter is
adorable you know and she does a good
job she's believable the young son for
the most part does a good job the
teenage daughter the performance is fine
but that character just ends up being
sort of a nothing character because
she's a different person every other
scene she's in this movie ultimately
starts to come apart and feel like a
market tested art by committee remake
where it's like okay what are the bullet
points we got a hit all right let's hit
those bullet points and when it does
finally introduce a couple new ideas
it's like they're not
in tune with the spirit of the movie
enough that they can overcome all the
stuff that's come before them so you end
up with this largely suspense lyst
by-the-numbers remake and I'm sad to say
that cuz I wanted this to be good I
wanted to like this I thought the
trailer was all right you know there are
some really cool shots there are some
really cool images here and there but
it's not altogether hard to get a cool
image in a movie now add a tree there
were some some neat little moments and
stuff like that this movie kind of has
two modes it's either winding up and
then never actually delivering a punch
or its punching you with no wind up and
for horror movie that kind of muddy is
any attempt in suspense there are and
you know three quarters of the way
through this movie I started to think to
myself you know maybe this movie isn't
made for me maybe through this movies
really made for is a kid about the age
of the Sun in the movie because certain
elements are changed to where he's kind
of taking the lead in some of the action
and that's fine and and from what I've
heard since seeing it you know the
director wanted to make this kid
accessible a family-friendly horror
movie and I'm down for the cause when it
comes to that I like that idea but I
don't think this movie handles it well
because you know certain scenes seem
like they're 2 pg-13 and too adult for
something of that intention and
ultimately I just can't really discern
any one specific vision with this the
rest of the movie it's either sort of a
bullet point checklist of poltergeist
moments or you know weird modern product
placement
this movie doesn't justify its existence
really beyond look now they have iphones
and a drone so it ultimately just
becomes kind of an uninspiring mess and
i want like i said i wanted to like this
i wanted to enjoy it i like you know sam
raimi's company produced this but you
know ultimately it just doesn't come
together and it doesn't do anything to
justify its existence it doesn't do
anything new or exciting you know this
movie sort of hits every pitfall that a
big studio horror movie remake hits
right down to the overuse of CGI because
all the major set pieces are CG and you
can tell like it's not necessarily bad
CG but it's also not necessarily very
good CG it's just kind of all right CJ
and when you have all right CG in a not
otherwise very interesting movie it
calls direct attention to itself you
know Carrie was the same way I know
people tend to harp on it a lot but you
really do wish for some kind of marriage
of practical and CG effects the most
effective moment in this entire movie
the only seen that really harbors any
suspense involves drywall and a drill
bit you know huh I feel like this whole
movie is kind of summed up in the
opening shot it's like the opening shot
is this really kind of gorgeous and
eerie macro image of these flowing
pixels and as it zooms out to reveal the
true image you know to reveal what we're
really looking at it's a video game on
an iPad and you know that's kind of what
this whole movie is is like oh here's
the interesting little thing and look
it's but it's modern though if you want
to watch a good poltergeist remake just
go watch insidious because you know
that's a total love letter to
poltergeist and it has some fresh ideas
to add to that mixed so as sad as I am
to say it as much as I wanted to like it
you know it ultimately comes out as
being kind of bland and uninspired and
I'm I'm sorry they didn't stick the
landing it's a bummer because like i
said the performances are good and there
are some fun moments when it seems like
actors were allowed to just play
with each other yeah poltergeist is the
movie um you know let's talk about this
there are some movies that you can argue
would be really great to remake so
what's something you would like to see a
remade you know and what's a remake you
think is particularly good or underrated
you know let's talk about that because I
don't think it's proper just to dismiss
remakes for what they are there are some
really good ones out there and there are
some like the thing and the fly there
are classics you know so yeah until next
time I am Jerry poltergeist 2015 is the
film cheers